o iPhone wallpaper playing on
e vai abrir também Parabéns que eu vou
comer eu e
e esse hoje foi o seu sepultamento e no
seu sepultamento você pudesse ouvir o
que as pessoas estão falando acerca de
você quando elas estou indo para sua
casa ou até mesmo quando quanto ela se
forem paradas ainda você venceu naquele
momento e se hoje fosse seus
recrutamento qual seriam as coisas que
você ouviria a seu respeito e isso
poderia ser só mais uma história mas tem
Total a ver com a minha história de vida
eu uso oito anos de idade eu perdi a
minha mãe e Naquele dia naquele
sepultamento eu fiquei refletindo a
certa dessa pergunta que eu te fiz uma
começar aqui eu fiquei refletindo de
tudo aquilo que eu ouvir ao longo
daquele dia eu fiquei refletindo quando
as pessoas me abraçavam e para acalentar
o meu coração É só alguma coisa que a
minha mãe fez o que ela deixou e isso
tem a ver com legado
o seu outro repetir para você o que que
as pessoas falaram a seu respeito quando
você fechar os olhos aqui nessa terra
você partir daqui o que que as pessoas
dirão de você ao longo dos cinco anos 10
anos que você partiu será que as pessoas
lembrarão de coisas boas que você fez os
fracos pessoas lembrarão mais de você
afinal de contas você tá deixando a sua
vida passar e não tem construído nada
sólido para que outras pessoas que
beneficiem sobre isso aos 18 anos a essa
daqui nós como seres humanos temos que
tomar tantas desses olhos que a gente
faz uma carta de habilitação que a gente
vai fazer uma faculdade que a gente vai
para um emprego Qual é o emprego e nesse
exato momento da minha vida eu estava
fazendo um turbilhão de emoções um
turbilhão de coisas dentro de mim e eu
quero te dar algumas dicas aqui
a resistência situações da nossa vida e
nós temos dois caminhos para seguir as
pessoas ou quando elas são vivendo mudo
quando elas estão vivendo um momento de
muita tristeza ou ela se afundam mais
elas vivem Elas comem elas respiram todo
dia da pena certeza e você deve conhecer
pessoas assim a sua volta pessoas que
você vai conversar e então situações que
viveram há dez anos cinco anos e elas
não conseguem prosseguir elas não
conseguem evoluir elas ficam estagnados
lá frases ou existe a segunda a segunda
exemplo e o segundo tipo de pessoa
aquelas que pegam essas situações
difíceis essas situações tristes e elas
conseguem potencializar e elas conseguem
voltar para os seus objetivos elas
conseguem falar OK eu vivi isso doeu e
ainda continua doendo
a luta de perder uma mãe que perdeu um
ente querido se você está viveu isso
você sabe do que eu tô falando é uma dor
que dói todos os dias mas a gente
precisar aprender a fazer com que aquela
dor ela não nos paralise então a minha
dica para você se você viveu e se você
está vivendo um momento como esse na sua
vida canalize toda a sua energia e
Acredite você é mais forte do que você
imagina pega toda essa energia e
canaliza para o seu propósito de vida
canais até os sonhos que tem dentro de
você não deixa criar uma situação para
você ao longo do caminho foi isso que
aconteceu na minha vida eu dizia o luto
eu vivia aquele momento de tristeza mas
eu peguei todas as energias que tinha
lembro de mim e alguns momentos confesso
para você que eu achei que não tinha nem
energia mas o mínimo de energia que
existia dentro de mim eu peguei e eu
tá pegando ao longo da minha vida para
potencializar para todos os sonhos que
eu queria alcançar na minha trajetória
existem três coisas que eu não abro mão
e eu quero deixar aqui para vocês também
para que contribua com a sua vida a
primeira coisa é o autoconhecimento Como
tem sido importante fundamental na minha
vida me conhecer quando mas eu me
conheço mas eu consigo me conectar com
maior número de pessoas e quando mais eu
me conheço mas eu consigo compreender o
outro quanto mais eu te conheço mas eu
consigo falar com as pessoas estão bem
ouvir Porque Nós seres humanos aqui
Existe Nós temos grandes dificuldades em
ouvir a gente é muito bom e falar mas a
gente às vezes não conseguem e se calar
e ouvir o que o outro tem a dizer tenha
algo conhecimento dos que isso hoje eles
tentando
não existem tantas formas que você pode
fazer isso e se conhecer foi o caminho
Libertador da minha história quanto mais
eu me conhecia eu aprendi Quais são os
primeiros eu aprendi Quais são os minhas
minhas qualidades e que eu posso e devo
potencializar eu aprendi e quais os
caminhos não são bons para mim porque aí
eu já sei os meus medos e eu tenho os
gatilhos que vão é vindo de encontro aos
meus Lemos Então a primeira dica para
você é se alto conheça a segunda dica é
não atende os nãos' que a vida te dá e
que as pessoas muitas vezes impõe o
nosso dia a dia imagina se eu tiver ele
sentado 2006 Quando eu cheguei em
Joinville e eu fui pedir uma
oportunidade de emprego numa empresa de
Joinville eo gestor comercial virou para
mim e disse você vendedora você não tem
se você nunca fosse graça uma vendedora
mais uma vez a vida colocando para mim a
oportunidade vou descer Ladeira abaixo
ou eu pegar toda aquela raiva daquela
frase deu dentro do meu coração e
potencializar para você a melhor
vendedora que eu podia ser naquele
momento com as ferramentas que eu tinha
e buscando cada vez mais conhecimento
sobre a área então não às vezes nos que
as pessoas te dão e não acende os irmãos
que a própria vida te impõe muitas vezes
existem situações na nossa vida como
essa que eu falei da morte da minha mãe
se ela cedo quando por milhão como um
rio nas nossas vidas e a gente não tem o
que fazer eu não posso presentear uma
parte da minha mãe não conseguiu prender
minha mãe tava bem de saúde de repente a
minha mãe já não estava mais entre nós
então até mesmo nessas situações não
aceite usamos
e aquilo de melhor que a vida é às vezes
impõe e que as pessoas muitas vezes nos
empurram goela baixa não gostei ti
porque você pode muito mais e a terceira
dica que eu quero te dar é para de
procrastinar cheia de procrastinação na
sua vida e na real você sabe que existem
coisas que você precisa mudar não é
amanhã não é agora que você precisa
mudar para você não é para os outros mas
que você precisa mudar para ter a sua
vida tenha novos resultados se você quer
novos resultados você já sabe você não
pode continuar fazendo as mesmas coisas
não tá dando certo então pare de
procrastinar cheia de procrastinação
existem coisas piores temos que fazer
que acharam sim é cansativo mas Nós
Somos adultos Nós não estamos mais uma
criança eu e você temos responsabilidade
do nosso dia a dia então para
E com isso a procrastinação ela não vai
te levar a lugar nenhum Então essa é
minha terceira dica para você e a grande
verdade é que toda a resposta que você
busca ela já tá dentro de você você tem
todas as respostas sabe todas as dúvidas
que você tem que você fala meu Deus eu
não sei qual é a resposta disso a grande
verdade é se você parar e escutar o seu
coração se você parar respirar é que a
gente devia muito agitado a gente vive
no mundo que existe tanto de nós e a
gente não para para silenciar e ouvir
aquilo que está dentro da gente então
acredite todas as respostas Elas já
estão dentro de você pare de buscar fora
pare de buscar em pessoas para te buscar
em circunstâncias pare de buscar em
coisas
e a resposta que já tá dentro de você e
se você parar e se você ficar um
pouquinho com você mesmo seja sua melhor
companhia e a maior companhia de todas e
nesses momentos que você tiver com você
busca as respostas de tudo aquilo que
tenha incomodado o seu coração então eu
quero voltar naquela frase que eu falei
para você aqui no começo o que que essas
pessoas falaram no teus pensamento o que
as pessoas falaram naquela semana que
você fechou os olhos aqui nessa terra
elas continuarão lembrando de você ou
melhor mas será que vocês estão fazendo
grandes coisas para deixar um legado
grandes as pessoas crescer e contribuir
a gente não vende só mundo para telas
conhecimento que foi a primeira dica que
eu te falei mas a gente também vê para
pegar toda essa bagagem de conhecimento
e a gente aplicar na
as pessoas à nossa volta na vida da
nossa família na sociedade onde a gente
mora na empresa onde a gente trabalha a
gente veio para deixar ligado Então eu
quero que você pense sobre isso o que as
pessoas fala não há cerca de você será
que você vai ser uma pessoa
insignificante trago você vai ser uma
pessoa Talvez das pessoas falem a esse
daí só foi mais um Eu não sei você mas
eu quero enquanto estiver nesta vida que
é uma só é única eu quero impactar o
maior número de pessoas eu quero um
contribuir com maior número de pessoas
eu quero fazer a diferença no maior
número de pessoas e isso tem a ver com
legal água quando minha mãe faleceu e
que eu pude ouvir tantas coisas boas de
terça dela naquele dia eu tomei uma
decisão a primeira Decisão foi se a
morte da minha mãe
e falou nada mais ara então no meu dia a
dia diante dos meus desafios quando eu
estou diante de algo que eu falo não vou
conseguir eu respiro fundo eu falo com a
Mariana a Mariana falando com a Mariana
e falei Lembra daquela menininha de 18
anos que fez uma promessa que aquele dia
naquele cemitério se aquilo não fará se
você nada mais padaria então não importa
o tamanho desafio talvez não resolva
naquele dia é verdade ele tem que duas
coisas na nossa vida que a gente tem que
refletir um pouco mais um pouco mais mas
com toda certeza eu vou resolver sabe
porque porque esse aquela situação de
luto não me pagou nada mais me para esse
é o mantra da minha vida é isso que eu
sigo todos os dias e a segunda coisa que
me marcou muito naquele velório na tela
naquele sepultamento quando eu fui para
casa foram as
me falaram acerca da minha mãe e eu
pensei puxa é isso que eu quero para mim
eu quero que as pessoas fazem Acerca das
coisas que eu fiz para ela coisas
histórias coisas que perdurem ao longo
dos anos e eu fiz uma promessa para mim
mesmo que eu queria fazer não só coisas
boas mas eu queria fazer coisas muito
muito boas eu queria não só ouvir
aquelas coisas que eu ouvi da minha mãe
mas eu queria ter oportunidade de fazer
coisas maiores e se ela fez porque sem
sombra de dúvida a o orgulho de qualquer
pai alugue de qualquer mãe é que o filho
se torne maior então isso também tem a
ver com o legado então a minha pergunta
para você é o que você quer deixar esse
mundo Quais são as respostas que você
precisa e não é ninguém que vai te dar
não já estão dentro de você e você tem
todas
as costas daí dentro e no dia que você
fechar o moleque nesta terra o que que
as pessoas dirão a seu respeito Ou
melhor o que que você quer que as
pessoas digam E como você quer se
lembrar